You've witnessed miracles,
blood drinking,
and saw much fire.
Let's answer
some burning questions.
Here is everything
you need to know
about Midnight Mass.
That wasn't an angel,
was it?
No.
It really, really wasn't.
What Monsignor Pruitt found
in that cave in the desert
was an all-out
Nosferatu-style
vampire creature
with bonus wings.
While he genuinely
initially saw it
as a saviour,
this was, in fact,
an ancient vampiric being
hiding in the shadows.
As showrunner Mike Flanagan
was growing up,
he was learning
about communion wine
at the same time
as getting into horror
and he saw direct parallels
between drinking the blood
of Jesus
and what he was reading
in Bram Stoker's Dracula.
This is where
this particular monster
comes from.
And Midnight Mass'
executive producer,
Trevor Macy, has explained
that this creature
actually has
very basic needs.
It eats, it seeks shelter,
and it has enough brains
to not just murder
the Monsignor,
but let him take him back
to Crockett Island.
But to fully explain
what happened here,
it's important
to talk about blood.
In vampire lore,
in order for a human
to transform
into a bloodsucker,
the monster
must feed on you,
and then, as life drains
from your body,
they force
you to drink their blood.
The consumption
of vampire blood is key.
This then creates
a fully-fledged vampire
and this transformation
is what we see take place
violently in the church
as the congregation
come back to life
with that tell-tale light
in their eyes.
As we all know,
on top of
an insatiable desire
for blood,
vampires
have an aversion to sunlight
as it literally
cooks them alive.
And, of course,
despite this one
looking pretty crusty,
they also have eternal youth
and the power
of fast healing.
Why was Monsignor Pruitt
able to go out
in the sunshine initially?
This is a great question.
If he'd been transformed
into a vampire,
how could Monsignor Pruitt
wonder around in the sun
when he initially arrives
on Crockett Island?
Well, it turns out
that the monster
didn't kill him
in that cave.
Despite the transfusion
of vampire blood
making him young again,
and taking him back
to the best version
of himself,
he was still human
and could, therefore,
transport the monster
in a box to the island.
It is only after
further consumption
of vampire blood
that Monsignor Pruitt
eventually succumbs,
as we see him die
on the floor
of his own home.
It's from this moment
that he becomes
a full-on vampire.
Which means the switch
over to nighttime ceremonies
from here on out.
Why did everyone
in the congregation
resurrect?
Unbeknownst to them,
the entire congregation
of Crockett Island
has been swigging
vampire blood
from the moment
that the Monsignor
returned to the island.
It turns out
that he's been lacing
the communion wine
with the stuff,
meaning he's been gradually
infecting the church-goers
with the blood.
Early on,
we catch a glimpse of him
tipping a hip flask
into the wine
before the altar boys
take it out.
Later on, we then see,
at the same time as Riley,
that the creature
has been opening a vein
and bleeding directly
into the communion wine.
Mmm, delicious.
This means
that everyone has gradually
been consuming the creature
and evolving
in a similar way
to the Monsignor.
This is why the members
of the congregation
have been so ready
to dance again
and even
no longer need glasses.
It also fully explains
the early miracle
of Leeza Scarborough
regaining
the use of her legs.
Despite being shot
in the spine by Joe,
the consumption
of vampire blood
gives her the power
to walk again.
Vampires are hunters.
They require speed,
strength, and agility.
When Monsignor Pruitt says
he's the best version
of himself,
that's what everyone else
is gradually becoming.
This means
that when everyone dies,
they have
enough vampire in them
that they will resurrect.
And it doesn't
seem to matter
how you die either.
Whether it's shooting...
throat slitting...
or the Jonestown-like
mass poisoning,
if you've had the communion
wine at some point,
you'll come back with
a serious thirst for gore.
It is worth noting, though,
that Riley was turned
by the monster
when he was killed,
as he hadn't been drinking
the communion wine.
How did Erin lose her baby?
Erin losing her baby
is directly correlated
to the consumption
of the vampire blood.
Sarah's
scientific conclusions
about the infection
riding the body of the baby
is absolutely right.
Vampire,
in essence, are dead.
They don't give life
and they don't procreate.
They consume
and consume only.
Unless
you're watching Twilight,
babies
and vampires don't mix.
The idea of the baby
just disappearing, though,
is particularly unique.
And Erin's test results,
showing that there was never
any baby at all,
means that her blood results
at that point,
are still normal,
even if, clearly,
they didn't put it
in direct sunlight,
like Sarah.
Fucking bonkers.
Why did so many people
turn evil?
Once half the congregation
of Crockett Island
resurrects in the church,
they turn
on the still human half,
treating them
like Bic Macs on legs.
And this is before
they're unleashed
upon the rest of the island.
But we have already seen
that Riley could still make
important decisions,
choosing to die
instead of facing his future
as a blood hungry monster.
And with
the Monsignor's help,
he fights against
his initial urges,
even the Monsignor
manages to fight his hunger.
In the incident with Joe,
he manages
to convince himself
it's God's message.
Riley's parents,
Annie and Ed,
also retain
complete control.
I'm starving too, but...
I didn't.
So, the congregation
do have the choice,
but they give in
to their hunger,
immediately becoming the mob
and consumed with the idea
of being saved.
Before he realises
the error of his ways,
the Monsignor
has them so convinced
that they
are the army of God,
that they succumb
to mob rule.
The right-wing
conspiracy theorist subtext
is strong here
as they slaughter
their family members
and drink their blood.
Only stopping with regret
when the truth,
quite literally,
dawns on them.
I don't know,
but I think I killed my mom.
Why didn't the Monsignor die
when he got shot
in the head?
Vampires aren't zombies.
It did take the Monsignor
a little while to resurrect
after he was shot
in the skull,
but even
a bullet to the brain
can't stop a vampire.
We never see
the old-fashioned garlic
or stakes being tried,
but the ancient vampire
is happy to wear
a religious robe
and walk in a church.
What we do see, though,
is that
the Monsignor's hand bleeds
when he holds a Rosary.
So, perhaps, this vampire
does have some more
stereotypical aspects.
Namely, a serious allergy
to touching crosses.
What was the relationship
between Monsignor Pruitt
and Sarah's mother?
It was a bit
of a late game reveal,
but it turns out that Sarah
is the illegitimate child
of the Monsignor
and her mother.
The reason
that the Monsignor
passionately made sure
he was giving her mother
the communion wine every day
was to restore the woman
he loved so much.
This cures her dementia
and gradually de-ages her,
making her look even younger
than her daughter.
A conversation
on the step of the church
reveals that Sarah
is their daughter
and that their lives could
never have been entwined
even if he had
left the church for her.
It's another
devasting reveal,
especially
as the Monsignor professes
how proud he is of Sarah
as she attempts
to destroy the church.
No, I've so proud of you
and I just wish,
I just wish that...
that we had gotten
to know each other.
Why could Leeza no longer
feel her legs at the end?
Leeza's sudden realisation
that she's
once again paralysed,
also might
answer the question
as to whether the creature
managed to fly away.
As Crockett Island burns
and its inhabitants
are incinerated
by the morning sun,
Leeza being paralysed
one more
is an indication
that the spell is broken.
I can't feel my legs.
The power of the blood
has been eradicated.
She is no longer
a vampire in waiting
and is a mere human again.
The irony is heart breaking,
but Leeza is no longer
going to become
a creature of the night.
The sun is rising
on a new day
where the vampire
has not won.
It also means
Erin's painful sacrifice
was not in vain
as she shredded
the creature's wings
with that knife.
It might not feel
like a happy ending,
but the survival
of Warren and Leeza
and a lack
of the vampires' power,
would suggest
that the nightmare
is indeed over.
So, hopefully,
that's all your questions
from Midnight Mass answered.
Let us know your theories
in the comments below
and remember to subscribe
to Still Watching Netflix
for more deep dives
into your favourite shows
and movies.